[Música]
bienvenidos a la entrevista de france 24
nuestro invitado de hoy es ser hija del
gobernador de la región de lugansk en el
este de ucrania nos acompaña desde un
lugar que no será revelado por razones
de seguridad muchas gracias por
acompañarnos
buenas tardes
considera que la contraofensiva
ucraniana en la región vecina de harker
choque ha sorprendido al mundo entero
está cambiando el rumbo de la guerra
y sin duda lo que pasó en la región de
jarquín volvió a demostrar la capacidad
del ejército ucraniano no sólo para
defenderse
sino para pasar a la contraofensiva y
derrotar al ejército ruso
en una ciudad y también en regiones
grandes
y la otra le sorprendió la retirada de
las tropas rusas en condiciones que
parecen bastante caóticas
no me sorprendió su retirada sino la
rapidez de esa retirada si se analizan
todas las campañas de rusia podemos
decir que rusia nunca ha librado una
guerra contra un adversario muy fuerte
entonces en el campo de batalla es muy
débil
por supuesto la siguiente pregunta es
por su región lugar
de lugansk es que usted va a concentrar
ahora la contraofensiva en lugar y de
manera más global en el donbass global
no sólo tumbas
lo diré de la siguiente manera en la
región de lugansk en una parte de la
región de los knicks
por supuesto continuaremos con la
desocupación habrá una contraofensiva
pero no es seguro que eso sea lo primero
para el presidente y para el estado
mayor militar de ucrania la vida de cada
soldado es importante entonces la
operación se preparará de manera
detallada y por ahora no podemos decir
mucho al respecto
esta región donde hubo batallas muy
duras como la de resistencia
quien ha visto a tropas rusas irse de
algunas localidades porque vieron lo que
pasó en la región de jarque y de las que
el 97 paseo de don joaquín quizás se
preocuparon
y no por ahora no por ahora las tropas
que huyeron de la región dejar que están
tratando de retirarse a nuestra región
para construir bastiones
precisamente por eso teme que la
resistencia que los rusos no pusieron en
la región dejar que manifieste en su
región lugar
y que allí vuelva a haber batalla es
extremadamente fuertes que afecten sobre
todo a los civiles sus recibí notamos
cañeros malar estamos muy preocupados
por los civiles
durante los cinco meses que han pasado
hemos tratado de evacuar la mayor
cantidad posible de personas de los
lugares donde ha habido combates
evacuamos a más de 300.000 civiles
desafortunadamente los civiles mueren
durante la guerra
si hay combates fuertes
le hacemos un llamado a la población
para que se quede en los refugios
se ha hablado mucho en occidente de
mucha o debord janka
janka
sobre esos presuntos crímenes de guerra
rusos que se han descubierto
en su región también se han descubierto
fosas comunes ataques deliberados contra
objetivos civiles es posible civil
y los principales crímenes de rusia se
conocerán una vez que nuestras regiones
hayan sido liberadas una vez que ucrania
haya sido liberada
pero ya hay ejemplos del comportamiento
bárbaro
y
sabemos muy bien que en las residencias
para adultos mayores han matado a los
discapacitados a los jubilados que han
ayudado a ucrania
[Música]
unas 50 personas murieron de esa manera
sabemos muy bien que los grupos de
refugiados que trataban de ser evacuados
también fueron fusilados
y 80 personas murieron pero las fosas
comunes más graves serán descubiertas
después de que se haya liberado la
región
sabemos que en esa región también en
donges que en otros lugares rusia
anunció muy recientemente que quería
llevar a cabo referendos de
autodeterminación
[Música]
se cree que a causa de la contraofensiva
ahora este proyecto es totalmente y
realista
sí claro los ocupantes ya dijeron que
quieren posponer la fecha del referéndum
prevista para el 8 de septiembre por un
tiempo indeterminado
evidentemente en esta contraofensiva
está la estrategia definida por el
comando militar ucraniano pero también
están las armas occidentales sin embargo
los occidentales dicen que no quieren
negarle a ucrania misiles de largo
alcance porque temen que sean usados
para atacar directamente el territorio
ruso
usted lamenta eso cree que sea un arma
importante tal vez no para utilizarla
pero sí para enfrentar el desafío frente
a los rusos
sin duda necesitamos ese armamento
podría ayudarnos a destruir los
depósitos que están en el territorio
ruso
y el pueblo ucraniano nuestro comando y
el presidente son personas muy
razonables
no buscamos ir al territorio de nuestros
vecinos disparar a las ciudades aunque
sean las ciudades del país agresor
no
cree que en unas semanas ver los meses
lugares sus regiones y que el cómo
quiera volver a estar bajo control
ucraniano incluyendo la zona que ha
estado ocupada desde hace varios años
por rusia y que ahora estamos cerca de
eso
sí sin dudas es el objetivo de todo el
pueblo ucraniano
el objetivo del presidente
él lo ha dicho varias veces debemos
desocupar todo el territorio de la
región de lugansk sin importar cuál sea
la fecha de ocupación 24 de febrero o
desde 2014 a todos
muchos temen que después de su retirada
los rusos se venguen un poco hemos visto
los ataques a la infraestructura en la
región de jarque
y
sólo cree que como la situación no está
yendo como ellos quieren los rusos se
venguen entre comillas contra la
población civil en su región civil
es lo que está pasando ahora
están destruyendo las presas de los ríos
están destruyendo las centrales térmicas
hoy bombardearon la ciudad de copian que
los civiles quedaron heridos
están tratando de destruir la
infraestructura de un país terrorista
como rusia se puede esperar todo
teme también que haya tentativas de
asesinatos selectivos contra dirigentes
como usted a nivel local
es algo que tiene en cuenta o cree que
es una amenaza un poco exagerado
no es para nada exagerado es una amenaza
muy real tratamos de ser muy prudentes y
siempre tratamos de mantener en secreto
nuestros desplazamientos
imagina que el presidente selenski a
quien vimos recientemente emisión en la
región de jarque que fue liberada
mira pronto a lugares que por las mismas
razones
watson y todo eso me gustaría mucho yo
mismo quisiera ir a nuestras localidades
liberadas
y con gusto me encontraría con nuestro
presidente en el lugar al que ella
[Música]
y hide a gobernador de la región de
lugansk en ucrania muchas gracias por
haber contestado a las preguntas de
france 24 y gracias a ustedes por
acompañarnos en esta nota
[Música]